poussins risques des explosifs et de
verglas
[Musique]
il fait vraiment ce que le gâteau le
faire de grandes révélations à propos de
mon cas paul pogba et de rappeler la
pinède à son avantage son amie sa
confidente celle qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui performeur puissants du
football et comme on l appelle ça se
modère quand sylvain musulmans
[Musique]
et j'estime que le public français
italien espagnol anglais mais elle est
de savoir certaines choses afin de
décider en toute connaissance de cause
s'ils veulent vraiment d'inspiration le
respect et l'amour l'amour du public
s'il mérite sa place dans l'équipe de
france et l'honneur de jouer la coupe
[Musique]
on
et il y aura des éléments du de nombreux
témoignages pour confirmer les propos
tout ça risque d'être explosif et de
faire graver tout sera révélé en temps
et en heure
[Musique]